never before by the way has the country
looked more divided on a central issue
and never before has it been so much
distrust between the Parliament and the
people this quiet corner safe corner of
South West London was suddenly the site
of of murders and murderous attacks on
women we want all of our students to
progress to this universities why not
they've got what it takes
they've got the ability we just need to
support them I never wanted to be a
singer I always want to be just the
writer and be at the back waterway kids
band in Westminster
[Music]
the Prime Minister fought furiously to
get her brexit plan approved by
Parliament but MP's chose that vote her
deal down in huge numbers the biggest
defeat our government has suffered in
modern history after that mrs. may face
the vote of no-confidence which she
survived for now but there remains the
problem of what next for brexit what she
has not in my view is a massive mandate
432 votes against her deal she takes it
back to Brussels and she says we can't
do this deal as it is read a fresh
approach 27 countries have made a deal I
think it's a good deal
if she comes to you and request some
concessions there might be a possibility
to give minor concessions but neither
Theresa May nor coffin would be able to
negotiate a much better deal let's just
prepare for no dear let self-confidence
let's have confidence in our own country
let's not be frightened let's take the
step forwards and go for no deal it
won't be as bad as a cliff edge crashing
out these are all these are all
remainder words we don't want these
remaining words they mean nothing we
want to manage managed no deal we're
almost three years down the road the
division is as as bad as it has ever
been if not worse neighbors families
friends even the political parties
everybody's divided that if we can't get
it together in almost three years I
think it's time to think again what they
want let me ask you about I mean the the
present process which is only just
started initiated last night by Teresa
may this process of trying to seek
consensus amongst parliamentarians and
and about the leader of your party about
mr. Corbyn in his decision not to engage
with Teresa may unless she takes no deal
off the table do you think that was wise
by mr. Corbyn well look she should take
no deal off the table as far as the
government's concerned I think our
argument is that Parliament is the only
place where no deal can be taken off the
table but she could say immediately that
the
government believes that No Deal should
not be the way for I think he's right
knowledge also said that well I think
he's right to ask her what she really
means when she says that she wants to
consult because if she can't take no
deal off the table then I think it is
very difficult for us to move forward
and get an agreement about a way forward
I am pretty sure that there is a big
majority in parliament against the No
Deal and I'm pretty sure that if we put
to the vote perhaps it will be a week
from now I think it's a week on Tuesday
that would be the agreement now if she
said that the government does not
support the New Deal option I think she
would be in a better place to be able to
chair these discussion I just don't know
yeah Jeremy Corbyn and her you know this
is this is this is political theater
that's what I wanted this is not going
to resolve this is ask you back resolve
the issue everybody knows that the
political theater your most experienced
politicians in the land and Theresa May
has made Jeremy Corbyn look intransigent
hasn't she I mean you know whether
whether she's the in transient one or
not only only time will tell but she
said let's talk to everyone that she's
talked to the leaders of all the other
parties in the other House of Commons in
theirs Jeremy Corbyn saying I won't do
it while the clock is ticking yeah but
look you know I had to deal with the
Conservative Party when we were in
government during the financial crisis
they originally said they were
supporting us and what we were doing and
then suddenly they pulled the rug and
their cooperation now you forget about
that nobody remembers that nobody will
remember this spat in a few days time
the serious issue the serious issue is
not can we have a one-off initiative to
get us through to Monday which is what
she's doing at the moment the serious
issue is can we devise and agree a
process by which the people can be
brought in as well as the politicians in
trying to resolve an issue that
Parliament at the moment can't resolve
their new claims against the serial
killer Levi Bellfield are to be
investigated he was jailed for life and
told he would never be released for the
murders of Milly Dowler Emily de
Lagrange and Marcia MacDonald well
several women have now come forward
alleging that they too were attacked by
him as after watching an ITV drama about
the police investigation young French
girl found a body on Twitter and boobs
and open his SiO I can now confirm that
her name was Emily
Delacroix we give this everything we've
got all right you got anything solid yes
sir
we've got on CCTV go
if we have to trace 25,000 vans and we
have to trace 25,000 bands chance of a
link to an attack near the grain a few
months ago
we dealt with missing in most 2002
isn't it possible there is a serial
killer Robin are you gonna listen to
that over me
your job is to get him off the pavement
before he hurts someone else
see utila gorge yes Detective Chief
Inspector Colin sir
well that TV series is based on the book
that was written by the former Detective
Chief Inspector Colin's son he worked in
the met murder scene your investigation
office from 2003 to 2011 and he joins us
now in the studio
Colin very warm welcome to you I was
binge watching its last night I had a
late night thanks to you you had very
little to go on didn't you
with this investigation that you needed
to get through in order to bring this
man to justice
how did you even know where to start we
were fortunate in that we were able to
get some information from the mobile
phone company from how many telegrams
each phone that gave us a likely area
where that phone had been disposed of
that told us that the murderer had
almost certainly driven away from the
scenes what was warm on Thames that
enabled us to define a CCTV area and it
kind of mushroomed from there there was
no forensic evidence no fingerprints no
scientific evidence so we had to sort of
start with that and then get gradually
work our way through two and a half
thousand hours or so CCTV that disclosed
to us a vehicle which looked very
suspicious and we went on from there how
long was it before you started
connecting what had happened to Emily to
the other girls well it was always in
the back of the mind from the very
beginning because you know this quiet
corner safe corner of southwest London
was suddenly the site of of murders and
murderous attacks on women it seemed
like an obvious conclusion together yet
your superiors were very clear what they
were dealing with the media that that
they had no reason to think that was
anything
the difficulty is if you formally linked
to crimes it means if you eliminate
somebody from one you eliminate him from
all the others so you can't really
formally link until you've got some
scientific clue
fingerprinting or DNA this makes you
certain it's the same person we didn't
have that in this case but what we did
say was that these crimes are so similar
the chances of them being committed by
two different people are so remote it
makes perfect sense for them more to be
investigated by the same team your team
was very large we've had a lot of cuts
haven't we to to police personnel do you
think of that investigation was
happening today that it how would it be
different it's a very good question I
would hope that it wouldn't be much
different at all when something like
this comes along it's like a once in a
generation thing that the phrase is not
very good at the moment is it but it
kind of happens and the Met Police have
got the resources somewhere to pull in
and flood that investigation for a short
time with lots of people I think I hope
that would still happen but there's no
doubt there's been a quarter of the
murder command has gone over the last 10
years so there isn't that resilience to
cope with things like this and there
would have been 10 years ago because of
the cuts Brampton Manor Academy in East
London is in one of the poorest boroughs
of the city but 41 of their students
have received offers to study at Oxford
and Cambridge University nearly all of
them are from a black and minority
ethnic background is like their dream
that is a sailor in the corner that we
approved to be a lot the school is
selective and interview processes take
place for candidates who want to study
here but I spoke to the head teacher
earlier and he told me that they don't
just base entries on grades they also
look at their potential outlook
[Music]
when we set up a sixth form in 2012 it
was our ambition to enable students from
this community to progress to the
Russell group of universities we've
always believed a Brampton Academy that
the children in our school and in the
New York community as a whole are
pregnant with potential they are
immensely able they can compete with the
very best in the world and we therefore
have embraced this mission
wholeheartedly to support them good
quality teaching constant support
encouragement inspiration has enabled
them to make this journey 40 of the 41
students that have received of this are
from a pame
background how important is that that
people are not getting into Oxford
absolutely very important because it
changes your narrative it changes the
narrative which is that children from
this background and as capable as their
peers or their more privileged peers and
it just simply confirms that they can
compete with the very best and as I said
this is just the tip of the iceberg as
more and more schools like ours join in
encouraging and inspiring these young
men and women to apply to this
prestigious universities we will find
that far far far more students we can
places it's top universities if I said
to you for example that we don't have a
single supply teacher in our school now
that is quite unusual we invest
massively in staffing we have small
class sizes we have cut down massively
on back-office functions and instead
invested huge sums of money we have a
university access team of five high
quality Oxbridge graduates that work
with students from year 7 all the way to
year 13 just two weeks ago we had a
professor of archaeology from Cambridge
University working with a group of year
8 students now that's the kind of
activity that's the kind of investment
that brings about the cultural change
the change in mindset the change in
aspiration the change in expectation
that enables students to progress to the
top universities in the world some
people may say well the interview
process could be a bit strict and you
may only pick the people that you think
are going to get into those Russell
Group universities is that the case no
that's absolutely not the case we look
at the context of every single student
that we interview because the context of
the GCSE school matters they may only
have an average of the grid B but you're
one of the top students in the school so
what we do is look at your story look at
your journey look at your ambition what
we say to every students that we
interview is that how tall how big is
your ambition will help you are you
prepared to work hard we will support
you to realize your dreams and can
enormous increase or is 41 element
absolutely the number can increase we
actually believe that the journeys only
begun and we will continue to inspire
encourage support our students we want
all of our students to progress to this
universities why not live cover takes
they've got the ability we just need to
support them and what we do here in from
a brand terminal Academy is find the key
to unlock the potential in every single
one of students that we are privileged
to work with
[Music]
welcome back now reducing the amount of
meat we eat every day to just what about
one bite of a sausage or a single
meatball could help save the planet and
lives
scientists are claiming ditching animal
products in favor of more vegetables and
pulses could prevent 11 million
premature deaths per year by 2050
celebrity chef and restauranteur Anthony
Worrell Thompson joins me here in the
studio so half a rasher of bacon a day
maxximum what do you make of this save
the planet diet well I think it's
admirable they've spent millions of
pounds coming up with this impractical
diet I mean what are we trying to do
kill something we're proud of in this
country we produce the best meat in the
world I mean forget great other things
vegetables whatever but we it's just
impractical and I have to really ask why
do we want a key 11 million people alive
longer than they naturally should live
and we've lived one of those threescore
years and ten and now it's up to 80 but
I just think let people enjoy themselves
a diet of nuts fruits vegetables it
would be better for us now it would be
but it's using your imagination to
create something out of takes a lot of
imagination create something out of nuts
and parses and seeds which none of which
we grow so what are you doing for carbon
footprint you're importing almonds from
California all the things that the
current vegan trend that some mangoes
from India
you know quinoa from South America so
the actual carbon footprint of a lot of
these ingredients that we're actually
starting to enjoy through vegetarian and
vegan diet so very bad for the planet as
well they claim the vegan diet you know
it would make a slimmer fit they say
would smell better even our sex lives
would be better they say yeah fair
enough but actually the diet they've
come up with is is roughly 200 to 300
calories more a day than we're eating at
the moment so really are we going to
reduce obesity yeah there are so many
heart related diseases from obesity
diabetes everything like that
I do believe you know we should actually
be looking at more things like food
waste we don't really need to eat nearly
as much as we we we should shop better
we should shop and buy fresh produce
when we need to eat it and and
everything like that buy in bulk but the
fresh produce that we so much gets
chucked away a third of our food gets
jumped away and and I can see it from
what comes back on the restaurant plates
I give to bigger portions so reduce the
portions and the customer looks at the
plate says well that's a bit mean but
I'd rather my waitress said to the
waiter said to the customer you can have
more if you want it yes and have a load
of food come back on the plate and go in
the bin
they hurried us aboard embarked for us
some leagues to see where had they
prepared a rotten carcass of a boat not
rigged not tackle sailed nor masts the
very rats instinctively had quitted
there they hoist us how can we assure by
Providence divine
miss Redgrave why the subject why now
because of the refugees they need our
help and as you've already said earlier
Anna Skye knows very well Skye do a
terrific job trying to focus so we
understand in this country how much help
we need to give in fact by the laws we
should be giving to these refugees from
war and violence the wars and the
violence continue and unfortunately
governments continue to sell arms and
that produces a lot of refugees and sky
did a great job on in showing what was
going on in the jungle which was later
closed and I went town with my producer
Carlo and went down with Alf Dobbs
Aftab Suzanne our film though I've been
concerned with refugees for a long time
because I'm an advocate I'm a volunteer
for UNICEF United Nations Children's
Fund and for UNHCR the United Nations
fund for Refugees so I've considerate my
bounden duty as a citizen to help
refugees I think what about those who
are critical and they say that some of
those who are children are masquerading
as children Athene some examples haven't
there of of people being found in the UK
it came across as children but they're
actually a lot older if you knew a time
you you you would understand that this
is picking out I mean obviously there
always be someone somewhere who's trying
to get in but without so you the reasons
for it but our refugees there from Wars
only people who don't know what's going
on can talk about with the handfuls and
I mean handfuls you see during the war
people helped each other and that's why
we final
one the more because what goes around
comes around if you want a blessing you
have to give a blessing as they say a
fans of Indian music have received some
welcome news with the British band The
Kooks announcing that they'll headline
this year's community festival at
Finsbury Park the band burst onto the
music scene over a decade ago producing
countless hits over a billion streams
and certified quadruple platinum album
now a new wave of fans is gonna have the
opportunity to see the river nature
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm joined now by band members hugh
harris and lee kricher thanks very much
for coming in so 15 years since you guys
got together seems like yesterday really
but this is gonna be apparently the
biggest headline that you've had why
this gig and why now
it's about time now it's amazing I think
we've just had like this resurgence and
like the young audience that seems to be
following us now that we don't really
know where it came from but you know
it's been great and the new album seems
to be you know maybe bringing some new
fans to us and it's it's streaming isn't
it Hugh that's I think absolutely that's
streaming everything yeah I mean once
where you'd have to kind of follow the
charts and kind of have a real kind of
engagement with what's going on in the
sales now it's kind of done for you you
can have kind of like genius mode on
iTunes or whatever on Spotify just
giving you kind of the same kind of
taste what you know so Luke when you
were a teenager and I'm singing in front
in there with your hairbrush alert and
then you got to go to the brick school
and 15 years on looking back has it been
has it been what you'd expected it well
I mean as much fun as you thought it was
gonna be
III never see I never wanted to be a
singer I always wanted to be just the
writer and be at the back and and then I
remember I played on Mondays I did you
know not so for me no it definitely
wasn't what I I thought would happen for
me I mean I thought I'd be in the studio
and and and not for me no I mean that
you could you dare to dream but no I
didn't really and I was more interested
in in the songwriting and the kind of
that stuff and I think the performing
came secondary for me but but but yeah I
mean oh quite ambitious
I think the moment I met Hugh I mean
that you like one of my chains and you
suggested me singing and so that kind of
been it then it kind of worked out
yeah only cuz I wasn't going yeah you
got a beautiful voice Oh
[Music]